we say we want colleges to be more
Equitable more accessible
but we tend to obsess over a tiny group
of colleges places like Harvard Stanford
Yale Princeton MIT but our cultural
obsession with a limited group of Highly
rejective colleges has major
consequences Regional public
universities or rpus for short are the
exact opposite rpus Pride themselves on
accepting everyone or almost everyone
who applies rpu students are more likely
to be first generation college students
like I was students of color low-income
students veterans so when you hear
someone saying oh anyone can get into
that school push them one way that's a
bad thing
you don't have to be rude about it you
could just say wow
that's amazing that that school gives so
many people the opportunity to go to
college